donc tu regardes une bande-annonce, tu veux
savoir de quoi il s'agit, je vais
me permettre d'expliquer
le fichier de noms et je suis un assassin ouais,
nous avons déjà vu tous les
films d'assassins et toutes leurs suites, n'est-ce pas,
tu sembles plutôt indemne, je vois
tout le monde a un gadget La
falaise de Carnot il est boucher et
se spécialise dans les têtes coupées et les
membres abattus faire un Mac ex
soldats de fortune turbocompressés des forces spéciales
Jane l'éventreur elle est la
machine à tuer les pièges à miel et les pieds empoisonnés pourquoi peut-il
être ainsi hors de lui-même Gaia et  quant
à moi, ce que je fais ressembler à
des accidents tous les jours, des accidents ordinaires
mais maintenant, mon Dieu, tu vois, l'amour de
ma vie vient d'arriver dans une boîte Six Feet
Under et je suis certain que c'était une de
mes équipes qui était pauvre là-bas.  je choisissais
mais lequel de ces branleurs l'a fait,
je vais le découvrir et quand je le ferai, il y
aura encore quelques accidents mortels
au coin de la rue, tu dois te lancer des balles,
n'est-ce pas
[Musique] regardons
dans l'ordre  pour frapper en laissant un
temps de récupération du contenu, les gars
et ce foutu Aldo a fait cette pensée, je
peux vous accidentellement
[Musique]